If you're watching this video then I'm pretty sure you love to travel, and you probably
love to eat.
Is there any better combination than traveling
for food?
Let me just quickly tell you who I am.
My name is Mark Wiens, I am a full time travel
eater, and right now I'm on a round the world
trip for food with Star Alliance.
I'm going to be traveling to nine different
cities, eating incredibly delicious local
food, and sharing all of the videos with you.
Welcome to Mumbai!
This has to be one of the most fascinating
street sandwiches I've ever seen made.
We have stopped by to order some mishkak.
Spicy sauce.
This is the camel hump.
That was a very good flight.
The view from the outside is spectacular.
The aroma of that meat and just the expertise
of how he is grilling it.
Right at the exit of the Metro.
In Rome we say, cheese like it rains.
Ok.
We just made it to the airport.
These shrimp are amazing.
I don't know if anything could get better
right now in the world.
Welcome to Lisbon.
This is definitely the biggest prawn I've
ever seen in my life.
Just check this!
Welcome to New York City!
It's almost breathtakingly beautiful.
And by the way, welcome to Hong Kong.
This has been one of my favorites since I
was a kid.
We just landed back at home in Bangkok.
That was the food trip of a lifetime.
Thank you to Star Alliance and their round
the world trip tickets for making this happen.
You can watch all of the videos on my YouTube
channel.
Go to Youtube.com/migrationology and also
click subscribe so you don't miss out on all
the delicious food videos.
See you on the videos!